foreign
we have to address
every word we would like to speak
in other words
and at the same time insufficient
for the families of the children that
have been killed
and the security guard
in the elementary schools
on behalf of all the members of the
government
[Music]
great sadness and condolences
all the people on the territories
and other areas where another murder was
committed
we would like to say
yeah
even though I know it was very difficult
for those people
I would like to say that we are united
in pain and sadness
foreign
with this repeated Mass
murderers
and then this random attack on just
of course
who was released
in front of their gate doing something
attack
Serbia
foreign
children grandparents lost their
grandchildren Mike mothers and fathers
lost their children
and for that very reason
they knew how to make the difficult
decisions
strength foreign
after the murder of these children
all of us were in a State of Shock
both of us whose job it is going to be
sober
razion
responsible serious zombies zombies we
basically walked around for 24 hours
explaining how and why
we were not able to answer those
questions
following that
is
with all the parents all over
and you know we in Serbia Imam
5005 276.
the parents were afraid worried
of course that's a consequence of what
happened
I expect my child to be safe in school
S
one person kills the children and the
security
how will we calm the parents what is it
that we can do
please call it we
[Music]
civilica
peer pressure in school which is a big
thing
stronger than them and the state for
sure is stronger than them
Vietnam
police officers sitting in those schools
there will be more I can tell you so
that they can have a replacement when
they have a day off and so on and so
forth
we have
traditional measures
more than what was mentioned in the
media this was a terrorist this was an
attack in which
is
interesting or neutralizing the
terrorists
foreign ER has been arrested
anymore the light of the outside
he will not leave
the truck strange things happened around
the world
foreign
affairs
um
waiting for 17 months or so the problem
is
really
um
foreign
find
the weapons
that have been used for the massacre
yesterday
says every six months or once a year
psychological
marvelousness
it doesn't exist because it's been that
way for 50 years
we know that there will be many problems
on account of that
the
Lord
our children and our citizens
on
um
including hunting weapons rifles in the
next two years
without any consequences
foreign
to five months as was the case until now
also
yeah
anything that is knife sharp objects or
anything that is a dangerous object
which is not necessary in schools which
can harm the students in any way
is also going to be restricted
even today
many parents suggested introducing metal
detectors
because the
uh the gun if he had seen him carry it
you have to continue
to live freely
find a way to
deal with this evil
is
until Monday
all of those who are trying to reach
their political goals
we have to help
our parents mothers grandparents we have
to help and Unite
foreign
on the territory of the Republic of
Serbia
where people reported falsely
cannot manage to to cover all of these
they cannot manage to arrest all of them
and yet we are responsible for every one
of them
I want to thank all of the units of the
minister of internal affairs
the Brigade
all of the services
I hope I didn't skip anyone all of the
units that were involved
to all of you of internal affairs
there were other people who knew where
the killer was and he they didn't let us
otherwise he would have been caught
sooner he would have been brought to the
face of Justice sooner
they will of course
be called
to explain
I ask people to stand by the side of
their state and the state will know how
to deal with the evildoers
do you think the parents
who in all of their fear and concern and
State of Shock have shown
a much more rational approach
a more serious
responsible approach than many
than men
and who did not behave that way
it's not easy for any one of us to stand
in front of you like this
especially when the times are difficult
to deal with their biggest
issues
Australians with the mass killings then
we will we serve it
and we will win
we also were in the situation
being Victorious but to we managed to
get image of many European countries
when it comes to salaries and other
things we will win this country
especially
lost their lives
what we might see what can we say to the
father and the mother and the question
brothers and grandmothers who have lost
it
a police officer and a sister
last night
because of a monster
did I skip anything did I forget
anything
did I forget anything
do you have any questions
I will be very brief how do we prevent
the rise of panic on social media I
think that's very important I think the
most important thing is not to prevent
Rising but to prevent lies
not just on social media but everywhere
killer
the various services and the police have
to take care of that today the decision
of the bureau is to raise the level of
protection in our entire country we will
have to work in accordance with the
measures that we have adopted two days
and the Darkness sites and all these
other places
if anyone says that it's killing someone
there is something relaxing or very good
then nicely you will go to jail and then
you can explain and we will look for the
support of Judges
um we will look for their support and
not to have to go through all these
Loops to search the uh house or the
apartment of the Killer and by the time
we get the uh order that the judge has
issued there is nothing in the house to
be found so as you know this might not
be in line with the European standards
and it's not but no it will be many
things in our country now will be
foreign
[Music]
right
thankful and aiming at people supposedly
immediately of course in accordance with
the laws
but what happened this was
called I kindly asked you know
information that the teacher died
as you can see no one is
we are not the murderers we are here to
fight against the murderers and Killers
we will win we will be victorious
together
to take pictures of what the killed
children
in foreign
unchecked unverified news I had last
night
can you please wait to get it on paper
it won't Escape unfortunately the news
they will not see
people in Serbia need to know that
Justice will be
and I mean smaller and bigger by age
only
huh some people will say to me
you're mixing your fingers
in the Judiciary business but I've been
called so many names I've been called an
idiot monkey and all of these things so
I don't care
I don't want to allow someone saying oh
you want to take my child away how is
that possible
how unaware
of what tragedy has been done in this
country
the last question go ahead
social work and all of the others
this is when you need to be with them
I beg of you be with the children now
it will be a big change
huge change
Plus
drug office Virginia Plus
an additional
security guard
let me says
when they send their child to school
maybe
because there will be someone there
protect the child
that's a big change
today
to bring back the deaths
and the government are against that
um
we can't do that I used to be against
the death sentence
I truly deeply regret having had that
political politics
second one was arrested you can see
we asked him why did you kill those
people
um
these
perhaps
and when he was being arrested he kept
saying respect respect to the police
officers
related to what you just said in the
statement did he give the motive for
this massacre
foreign
did I use the right word is that what he
said
so you
jumped there and you you disbelieved
what you just heard
my second question is you said
um it's important to prevent the
spreading of lies and in relationship to
that there's disinformation saying that
state of emergency is being introduced
what do you say to that is that a
disinformation is that true or not and
the last question even though you said
you will not speak about those who use
this tragedy for political purposes I
think you don't have the right to keep
quiet because they jeopardize people
they upset
until Monday it's days of sorrow and the
government will say these three days are
days of Sorrow for the um
for the victims
and by Monday
before Monday I will not say a word as
of Monday I will say everything I think
about what they're doing against their
people and their country but I won't say
it before Monday
all of those wheeling and dealing whose
only goal is
to have our people unhappy as unhappy as
possible so that it is as good as
possible for them
is the strongest always when it's the
most difficult
horrible law says during the floods
some people were saying we should fry
some in the in the events or whatever
I don't know what they're saying thieves
so today the same thing
proud of the responsible degree and
these seriousness
that our mothers are showing mothers and
grandmothers are showing
those women
citizens of Serbia win
compared to them they are strong they
are wonderful by their side
evil doers will not be able to win over
Serbia and it's true for the freedom
they will not succeed in winning
six million seven hundred thousand
people because we will not allow for the
lives of these angels to be forgotten
um
the most experience and they know it so
in the next 15 days you will see a
greater presence
of police officers and so on and after
that we will go back but we will never
forget the horrible sacrifice
and the loss and that's why we will
change
we need knowledge
with this we his press conference